vinod joins us from Arizona - ah welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks
for taking my call
sure how can I help so um I want to ask
you whether it's smart to take a
personal loan to finish backyard with a
pool or pay cash for it or not even do
it um I started to follow your steps
last year and the wages though we make a
decent money and my next goal is to nail
down the house that's the only that we
have but then I forgot that we actually
have a backyard and it's not finished
we have $15,000 cash between me and my
husband we can use it or because we have
separate financial account and
everything I do have some extra cash I
can do poor but it's a lot of investment
a lot of money I'll um hear what you
think now the only way I would do it is
if you pay cash for it otherwise you
need to just landscape the backyard and
forget it and the only reason you would
put in a pool is twofold one is you
would enjoy it and two is there's enough
pools in your neighborhood that it
raises the value of your home close to
what you spend on the pool it almost
never raises it what you do yeah but it
will raise it some in some neighborhoods
but if you're if you're the only home in
a mile radius that has a pool it won't
raise it at all but if you if most homes
in your area have a pool and you don't
you may see a kick of what you spend if
you keep a reasonable budget on a pool I
mean you can spend three hundred
thousand bucks on pool you have to be
careful yeah and so you know what you
know I would talk to a good real estate
agent and say okay how much of this can
I plan on recouping and then you say
okay the amount above that I've got to
enjoy it that much mm-hmm while I'm here
which is a thousand dollars an hour to
swim in this thing or what is it I mean
you know what's it cost you and you've
got to look at the joy of it
as part of it but I would never do any
of it without paying cash Chris yeah
what how much are you planning to spend
on this pool what's the budget um
we're hoping to do 45 to 55 it's a pool
and a spa well we want to stay in that
budget but I think you know after tax
and everything probably under 60 I think
60 is Mike what's your hand I limit my
home is 380 to 400 400 so you're going
to increase your home by value by 15%
with a blue I doubt it
yeah okay you all planning to stay there
I want to stay as long as we can and uh
yeah I want to stay till we retire as
grandparents yeah but now you said
something else they caught mine you know
Dave and I we listen pay attention why
do you and your husband have separate
finances um you know this is his
preference unfortunately we don't have a
perfect marriage I don't feel like we
have I I don't know I don't think you
have a trust war and you know there are
some cultural issues too I'm not
I'm originally from China I'm a big
favor and me and my family were very
close generally help support each other
we never take loans we try to pay cash
for everything and yeah I had the very
beginning of our marriage I wanted
blending everything but he didn't want
to you know wait we kept it that way it
it hurts sometimes you know when you
have to talk money with your spouse
while I was listening to your shows well
the biggest thing you know you guys have
a family a lot and unfortunately we're
just not a couple that getting on the
same page all the time so and you guys
have been married how long nine years
okay three children and how much debt
have you all paid off together um I I
don't have any dad when I stopped name
is marriage and he he has car I
encouraged him to pay off his car car
loans and his student loans and
everything and we just a refinance or a
house a horseman we cannot do 15 years
and uh you
cannot imagine how long it took us to
refinance because he doesn't want to UM
yeah it took us all this five months to
refinance
well I think all of those issues are
much bigger issues than the pool there's
something if I were you I'd be working
on but aside from that the pool answer
is cash or don't do it and B I would
talk to a real estate agent and say if
we spend $50,000 on a pool which is you
said forty five to sixty if you spend
$50,000 on a pool what is it going to
increase the value of our home and if
they say ten thousand dollars then you
know this is a bad idea if they say
it'll increase it thirty thousand
dollars and you're gonna be there a few
years then maybe you get twenty thousand
dollars worth of enjoyment but that's
something you guys just need to say
we're going to the amount that you're
the call enjoyment we're gonna blow that
money just blow it we're just gonna
consume it it's not going on a vacation
forthrightly twenty thousand bucks right
we're just gonna blow it and that's an
okay thing to do if you have the money
number one and if you're paying cash for
it and and and if you've actually said
it out loud
I mean Sharon and I look at doing some
things we're gonna put we've lived like
no one else now we live and give like no
one else and so there's times that we
look at a trip and we go wow that's
super luxurious super expensive I grew
up in Antioch Tennessee that feels very
weird to spend that much money on that
and then we go well here's how much we
gave last year and you know ministries
and here's how much we spend on other
parts of our life and here's what our
income is and it's really a small amount
of all of that so it's okay yeah you
know but we have to say out loud we're
blowing that and that's emotionally
weird we're just consuming that money
you do need to enjoy some of your money
though well you really do and Dave
you've teach you've taught and me and
years ago talking about ratios and it is
important and unfortunately you know a
lot of people on our society they will
look down upon people who have worked
hard and sacrificed hard and enjoy and
you know that's where you have to really
and truly understand that opinions are
like yesterday's everybody's got them
and so what you have to do is really
stay focused and true to what you're
doing and your goals